hey youtubers it's Charlie so I was
totally working on another video and
started making so many announcements
that I just needed to make a separate
announcements video so I hallucinate it
that it'd be a good idea to do something
called the emergency awesome facepalm
and it'll be like a new weekly video
series where I make announcements talk
about like fun behind-the-scenes stuff
that I'm working on horrified derp on
some giant video there's some big air
that I didn't see whenever I posted
something
so just to general these videos will be
a little bit more informal like a little
more vloggy I know a lot of you have
asked for me to start doing vlogs and
podcast these stuff I'm not planning on
doing a podcast anytime soon but I did
need a video where I could just explain
stuff that didn't necessarily fit into
like a game of Thrones or a Star Wars
video I'm hoping this is gonna make it
easier for me to do episode videos and
movie videos without having to cram a
bunch of announcements into each of
those once I find a thumbnail design
that I settle on I'll just I'll make all
the thumbnails the same so it'll be
really easy to find so if you want to
know what videos I'm gonna be posting
each week or what I did last week it'll
be really easy to find that I'll even
put a playlist on the home page here
just so it's really easy for you guys to
find this is gonna be facepalm number
one so next week I'll post facepalm
number two so what I'm planning is is
keeping these emergency awesome facepalm
videos to five minutes in length if I
feel like it needs to be longer or
something I'll just do a live which Q &
A or a stream or something like that I
am planning on doing more streaming so
if there is something that I'm planning
ahead of time I will mention it in one
of these videos so with that in mind
here actually here's the videos that I'm
working on this week so there is let me
look at my list here flash episode 10
that's tonight last airbender episode 3
that was gonna be that was the other
video I was working on where I started
making too many announcements that'll be
tomorrow morning then arrow episode 10
then a Q&A for flash arrow DC stuff then
a new Marvel Inhumans Avengers video
then Constantine episode 10 then a new
Star Wars bonus video new Game of
Thrones bonus video then new Walking
Dead and then emergency facepalm number
2 if something really crazy happens in
between there I might cram one in but
those are the videos that I'm planning
right now my biggest priorities this
year are 1 keeping to my schedule so if
I say I'm gonna post Game of Thrones and
walking dead on Sunday I actually post
those videos on Sunday what I'm working
on is that my video schedule follows the
TV
schedule so if something airs on a
certain night you can look for that
video later that night the exception
being like agents of shield for example
there are a couple nights a week when
there are a couple different shows and I
can only make so many videos in a
certain amount of time so shield videos
always post Wednesday mornings keeping
my schedule would just mean posting
those shield videos every Wednesday
morning at the same time I'm always
changing like little things about the
way I make videos so sometimes it takes
me a little bit longer to get stuff out
eventually I'm just gonna like settle on
something so it'll be a little bit
easier to hit that schedule like post
the videos at the same time every day
priority number two this is actually
really a big one is working subtitles
nothing bugs me more than YouTube
derping subtitles on the videos I post
so what I'm gonna be doing is just
manually posting English subs for
everything I partnered with YouTube to
test out their new fansubs feature - so
now you can actually submit your own
subtitles for any of my videos it's kind
of hard to find the menu but what you do
is you click on the widget here on the
video page and you just you click on
this add subtitles button it'll take you
to the page where you can transcribe
your own subs once you submit those and
I see them on the back end of my channel
I can enable them and you'll actually
like YouTube has a thing where I'll
actually give you credit
anyone that submits fansubs for any of
my videos will totally get shoutouts
because you are automatically awesome in
my book all of you guys who can't hear
my videos really well or don't speak
English you are really important to me
so it's my hope that better subtitles
will make it easier for you guys to
participate so that's that's really the
important stuff you know better
subtitles sticking to the schedule I
know I know it sounds really simple I
always find that it's less stressful if
you just make your goals really simple
but those are two really important goals
so the next edition of emergency awesome
facepalm will be a little bit more fun
it'll be more fun stuff there were just
a few announcements that I wanted to
give out on this video there's some
really cool stuff happening next week
and I will post the schedule in the
video description generally if you check
the descriptions usually that's where a
lot of the extra information goes like
links for social all that stuff I'll be
posting my video schedule to social -
I'm trying to make special videos for
that like really short videos for
Facebook Twitter Tumblr all those other
places and if there's like something
longer that I want to talk about like it
is a Q&A that I want to do for a longer
period of time I'll just do that on
Twitch if you have any special requests
for stuff you want me to include in
these
just just let me know in the comments
I'm always happy to include stuff just
remember I'll be keeping the videos
below five minutes in length there's a
whole lot of awesome stuff happening
this year that I'm really excited about
hopefully I'll have the opportunity to
make videos for most of it even if I hit
like half of it I'll be happy but be
sure to subscribe to get everything
so next emergency facepalm will post
next week if you haven't seen it yet you
can click here for my Gotham episode
from last night and you can click here
to get ready for arrow in the flash this
week thank you so much for watching so
let's all high-five I will see you guys
tonight